Look at you.
Um,
I'm enjoying this gem.
I wish we had a speed bag.
That's my favorite thing to one a test.
Steve Sweeney,
ladies and gentlemen,
how are you?
Hey,
I'm great.
I can't sell it.
You know what?
I've done so many things in my life.
You know,
movies,
TV,
all this stuff.
Stand up.
But Joe Falcon,
oh my God.
Jack and blast and Jesus have Rancho Rankin.
Yeah,
I get you got fans,
you know that.
Oh,
like all these different ages and all different kinds of people and I'm very
proud of you.
Thank you.
One of the things that happened,
you don't remember this,
but you opened for me many times.
Louis C K opened for me.
Nick Dipaolo open for me.
So people that want a little show business advice open for me.
It helps that.
Then you get to go by me and uh,
you know,
I get to watch you guys become stars.
I've said I'm playing fucking Chinese for us in Saugus,
some of the best standup comedy in the world is at Chinese restaurants and
Sagas.
And that's a fact still to this day.
All those people that live there,
they don't know how good they have it.
Well,
you know what it is,
you know,
you work with these guys.
You and I have worked with guys that are like genius,
you know,
a transcendent,
whatever word you want to use.
But
doing stand up is not about being funny.
It's about going into these shit holes and like developing this extra skin.
You know,
you,
you're a martial artist and sort of,
you have kind of that mentality.
But you know,
when I started it was like,
I came from,
you know,
I was an actor,
I was very serious person.
I was like an actor,
you know,
and I,
I do like these obscure impressions.
I,
Paul Scofield and Lawrence,
Lawrence,
Olivia,
you know,
all right,
it's on ads and all this bullshit.
And I'd be playing at places like the sugar shack.
So you remember this shit.
It was a black,
uh,
R and B joint and I opened for BB King.
Wow.
Yeah.
And I'm dealing like John Lennon.
It was very important when we started them and the black do some dirty shit,
man.
What the fuck you don't,
you know,
any jokes.
So in the back,
I get heckled,
my first heckler,
Yo suck.
And I said,
yeah,
fuck you.
Who are you?
He says,
I'm BB King.
I hired you motherfucker.
Oh No.
And then I was doing,
I will never forget this.
Do you remember the channel?
The channel?
Yeah.
Channel a little rock,
rock and roll place.
So I'm opening for like these bands,
you know,
it was like that blues brothers scenes where the thrown shit at the cage.
Yeah.
So,
um,
barter,
he says,
you know,
point to people and we'll throw him out.
So I point to them,
but then they bring them out in the alley and beat the shit out of him,
you know,
but I,
I'm thinking because you're a martial artist.
So I kinda got this thing about people fighting and grown up in Charlestown.
And,
um,
I think back on certain incidents when I was starting doing standup and I was at
this place and calm AV and this guy stole one of my lines.
I know that you're bringing it to that,
right?
So he goes off stage.
I hit him with a right cross fucking cause over the tables.
And I'm thinking to myself,
my friend says,
I thought you wanted to be Jonathan Winters and reds.
They don't do shit like that.
And then another time we were at the ground round in Brighton,
I'll never forget round round.
Yeah.
I'll never forget this Joe.
So I'm on the guy on before me.
The guy in the audience is throwing little ice things that I'm right.
So I said,
uh,
my opening line,
usually it's trying to get the audience to light cue,
you know,
or make them laugh or whatever.
So my opening line was like the first motherfucker that throws something at me,
I'm going to knock them out.
You know,
you're not exactly setting the stage for a hilarious comedy,
but uh,
you know,
what's that?
How'd that work out?
Terrible.
I bombed.
You know,
people think,
you know,
when you do this for a while,
you'd never bombed.
I mean,
there's no experience in life like bombing in Louisville,
Kentucky.
I'll never forget that.
And a guy comes up to me afterwards and he says,
and he was trying to make me feel good.
He says,
well,
I could tell by your tone,
your funny.
Ah,
you know,
but I'm doing shit like about subways and stuff.
They don't even know what they are.
Right.
So those early years,
there was like one,
um,
there wasn't even a comedy clubs.
So you just kinda did it.
I fell into it.
What year did you start?
Oh my God.
People,
you know,
people I am now at that point,
Joe,
what people come up to me and you know,
they say,
I'm so glad to see you.
I keep telling my husband,
I'm telling you he's not dead.
He is not tied.
So it's been like 30 or 40 years.
Um,
I don't remember the year,
but uh,
I remember those over the year.
You started?
No,
I don't remember.
I started in [inaudible] 88.
And you were a legend.
I was allergic.
But you were for sure.
Dude,
I watched you one night at Nick's comedy.
Stop kill so hard.
I start,
I thought about quitting because I'd only been doing comedy like a year and I
was like,
fuck this.
I could,
I gotta get the fuck out of,
you know what I had that feeling Richard Pryor's first performance film.
Do you remember that?
Yeah,
yeah.
Richard Pryor live.
We filled it in Long Beach.
I was,
I went to see that with Steven Wright and both of us walked out.
We said,
we don't even want to do this.
You know,
it was so intimidating.
I know that feeling.
Well,
you know,
we got that feeling a lot in Boston and uh,
as,
as a kid starting out there,
it was,
I tell everybody that I,
I stumbled into the,
the greatest comedy scene in the history of the known universe in 1988 when I
started.
It was insane.
Dawn Gavin was in his prime.
You were in your prime.
Roger Sin.
I would watch these guys go up.
Um,
there was so many guys that were so fucking good.
Knox was killing back then.
There was so many guys that you would go any night you would go and watch some
of the best standup comedy on the planet.
It was,
it was amazing.
Mike Donovan,
to this day,
people don't know who Mike Donovan is.
He was a fucking Johnny most,
you know who Johnny Mo.
Most people don't know.
10 by Rad side.
Yeah,
he would do this long.
But you know what Johnny,
but it's funny you say in your prime because,
and I've talked to people who've been at it longer than me.
This is one job where you can get better.
Yes,
you can get better,
more skillful,
you know?
But it's something that you,
you know,
you,
you just have to give the finger to the business because they're looking for the
fat guy,
the small guy,
the black guy that you know,
they're,
they're always looking for something other than what you are.
So you do what you do.
Like you've done what you did
business in terms of like movies and television shows.
Yeah.
They will try to lure you away and they lure you away with money.
But the business has standup comedy is,
it's really about what you do in front of that microphone.
You know,
how the audience responds on
stage.
I followed a woman and uh,
she had a lot of TV credits,
but she had no material and it was unbelievable.
You know,
you forget when you do something,
you forget.
It's like you're a trained fighter,
you're trank radio person.
You forget that in order to do it,
you've developed a certain set of skills.
Yeah.
And like in Boston they have a St Patrick's day breakfast where the politicians
try to be funny and it's excruciating.
You know what I mean?
And you forget,
Oh yeah,
I do this all the time.
It'd be like me trying to give a speech before I came on the show,
I talked to Nick Depalo,
you know your buddy.
Sure.
And he says,
well,
Joe and I always talk about politics.
And I said,
well,
no,
nobody would help himself.
Nobody.
Nobody talks to me about Paula.
I'm just not that smart.
Good.
I'm done with politics.
I'm going to quit.
Yeah.
I want to talk about it.
You know,
where we are in this country now is like,
um,
well I,
I,
I kind of,
uh,
I don't like to not like someone because of what they believe.
So I just kinda do silly shit.
I was thinking the other day with the Democrats,
you know,
I'm gonna run,
I'm gonna run that,
but they got the moderate lane,
the Progressive Lane,
so I'm going to run in the breakdown lane.
You know,
it's just a silly little shit,
you know?
Uh,
I try to keep it upbeat,
whatever,
but I got into this,
I fell into this because I kept thinking I'm going to get an acting job and I
won't do stand up up.
This is gonna fuck an end at some point.
You know what I mean?
And I,
I have,
you know,
like people,
kids would,
will actually ask me for advice and I say,
advice,
are you shitting me?
I fell into this shit.
I expected it to end,
but he,
I say,
all right,
you want some advice?
Don't ever work at a place that's named after the guy.
Like if it's Vinnie's fucking pizza parlor,
a Joey shared whole Bobby's moneymaking piece of shit.
When it's named after the guide,
it's never enough.
You know Nick's comedy.
Stop.
Nick's.
Now I'm going to do something.
Feel okay.
We're going to play a little scene.
Okay.
Now you ask me.
Say is Nixa mafia joint is Nixa mafia joint.
Yeah.
Is this this next till around a hundred percent yeah.
Nick's is around.
Was it the same ownership and do you know that there isn't one inch of that
building that I didn't do coke,
cocaine.
I believe that it was.
It was really something.
I mean it was like,
I know that,
you know,
I lived in La many years ago and it's like I'm driving around and say,
oh,
I know that spot.
So with Nick's,
I know every spot in the building.
By the way,
I didn't know that this was a camp area.
Oh,
see all the campers?
Yeah.
Right out in front of you of the place.
They're everywhere.
They finally side streets where the cops won't kick them out.
Yeah.
And semi homeless people.
They're not homeless,
they just have mobile homes.
You know what it is that the homeless people here are so peaceful there like,
uh,
like the caravan,
you know,
they're just,
they don't bump change,
they don't do anything.
They just kind of walk around.
I'm,
I'm sitting in front of your building here.
It was like a fashion show for the homeless.
One guy comes by with a buffalo bills jacket and the other guys then,
you know,
and they just quietly talking to themselves,
some welcome gung back and you know,
it's freaking me out.
I've only been here 12 hours,
but
everybody is either really soft spoken or I'm losing my fucking hearing because
like,
even though I'm renting the car and the woman says,
teaching a Honda,
do you want us,
I said,
why?
What did you want a son?
That's what you know,
in Boston it'd be like,
what do you want for a cat?
You want to be out of graded.
It's like the noise pollution.
Well,
it's louder there and colder and people are angrier.
It's a different place out here.
It's just,
even the homeless people,
they don't have it so rough.
If you're going to be a homeless person,
this is the place to go.
People are very open minded.
It's relaxed,
it's warm.
I mean the cold as it gets,
it's like 40.
That's as cold as it ever gets.
Yeah.
But you know,
if you're giving advice to homeless people,
it's like,
like I was,
I was sitting in Westwood and a Starbucks.
Right.
And it's,
the guy was just sitting there,
you know,
and all these people are having their lattes and shit and he's just,
you
know one of those crazy laughs,
everybody's just gone along with their conversation,
you know,
the,
uh,
I don't know what to say about the,
about the homeless thing.
Have you ever been downtown?
Do you ever seen I might get,
Oh,
I myself was homeless when I was like 16.
I was a hippie and his father passed away when I was 15 and it was a different
time,
you know?
No,
I haven't been down.
So you were almost for like how long?
I was a hippy and it's different than being homeless,
but a couple of years.
Really.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
you know,
the worst moment I was lying,
I was downstairs in this guy's house and I overheard his girlfriends saying no.
He was saying it was girlfriend.
I don't know.
I keep asking the guy to leave,
but you know,
I was,
you know,
here's what happened to me,
Joe.
I've read Jack Kerouac on the road.
Okay.
So I wanted to beat Jack Carol whack and I wanted to be a writer.
So I did everything that Carol.
I did except right.
You know,
it was living in YMCAs and drinking the wine and the whole thing,
but it was a whole different country then.
Why didn't you start writing was one of those things like eventually you'll
start writing or writing.
I wanted to be a writer.
I didn't want to fucking right.
You know what I mean?
Right.
Like you might need the hardest,
you don't want to paint and write.
Writing's the hardest job in the world.
I don't know how people do it,
but we did this movie,
which I'd like to mention a bill Broaddus wrote this movie.
It's called Sweeney killing Sweeney and a,
you can get it on iTunes.
It's out right now,
preorder it,
when's it out?
It's going to be the middle of March,
but they can preorder it.
Okay.
But,
um,
this guy,
bill Broaddus wrote this script and I'd split my twentysomething movie.
I've been in a lot,
done a lot of acting,
and I said,
this thing is so good and I want it to be able to get guys who I knew were
tremendously talented
to,
uh,
not be in these clubs.
You know?
Um,
it's very like demeaning sometimes,
you know,
for a guy who's really good at what he does and somebody like texting and you
know,
all this bullshit.
Like I had a woman,
uh,
you know,
usually I'm like okay about it,
I say,
okay,
listen,
you putting us out of work,
like in the future I'll text you a joke.
Then you text back,
lol,
you know,
silly little shit.
But I had one woman and she's the arrogance,
you know,
and it was a benefit to,
and she's doing this and
she said [inaudible] and multitask.
So I said,
okay,
so when I stick it up your ass,
he's still going to be able to talk and everything.
You know what I mean?
So I see guys like Steven Wright,
who's in the movie,
Nick Depalo,
Bobby Slayton,
uh,
Jonathan Katz,
you know,
all different styles of comedy to Lenny Clarke and Tony Vee and Frank Santa's
Raleigh.
I wanted to,
I wanted to see them get in something where we could really work,
you know,
and they all did it.
They were all in the movie and it was a fantastic experience.
Woman director,
Lisa Amala,
and it was just,
it was great.
It's the first time I produced a movie,
which is really hard.
What is it?
Uh,
like a dramatic movie?
Like what is it?
I'll tell you the plot briefly.
No,
I guess it's a comedy,
but it has its moments.
Is the HBO maybe or showtime or some company comes to town
and they want me,
but they say the characters,
the two local,
you've got to get rid of the character.
So then my character's try to kill me.
So I played five different parts.
Six like a Peter Sellers kind of thing from Dr. Strange,
like you're losing your mind,
like your characters are trying to figure that out.
Okay.
Yeah.
You don't know whether I'm losing my mind.
Um,
but I had just come off the equalizer with Denzel Washington.
I was in that and uh,
that was an interesting experience because like,
I got this beard,
you know,
and I'm the director we did training day.
He said to me,
you know,
you got to save your beard.
And I said,
listen man,
I saw my face 25 years ago.
It scared the shit out of me.
This beard is here for a reason.
I'm the most ugly motherfucker up of saying I can't do it.
Then he told me how much money I was going to make.
I said,
would you like me to shave my balls to similar experience?
Something about Mary.
So my scene,
if you haven't seen it,
Ben Stiller's things caught in the zipper.
So I,
uh,
I'm a cop.
I come in the window and Peter Directed,
I said,
do you know I don't have to grab his Crotch,
right?
He says,
yeah,
you're an actor.
You got to grab it.
I said,
I don't have anything against it,
but I just,
I just can't do it.
Then he told me how was money I was going to make.
I said,
you want me to just grab it cause I'll give him anyway.
Uh,
that was my experience with that.
Do you really feel
demeaning work in clubs is,
I still enjoy working clubs.
I love it.
I mean out here,
of course we do the comedy store all the time.
I do the Improv,
but I do clubs on the road
are easy.
They're great.
They're there in the laugh.
You mean like shitty clubs?
You mean like a bar gigs,
you know,
hit.
Here's the thing is when I'm on stage I'm okay,
you know,
but when I'm driving to fucking East Methuen elk club,
it bothers you that I get a fucking depression.
You wouldn't believe it.
You start to feel old in the day.
Like driving to those gigs was awesome.
Yeah.
Right.
Like something shifts.
Like what is it that shifts?
Is it,
is it in your own head?
is it just that you've done too many of them know and I think shifts is you
stopped drinking.
Ah,
I've been sober 26 years.
That's the problem.
Yeah.
I'd say to my kept drinking my career would be through the roof,
you know.
Um,
no,
there are great clubs.
Giggles is a great club.
Greg Club route one on so good pizza too.
And good pizza.
And I'll do a theater.
I love that.
Uh,
I'm just giving you the other side of the story because you know,
people do get into this and they don't have an idea of what the life is like.
You know what I mean?
To be on the road and like a lot of my friends and now doing cruise ships,
those are depressing.
You're trapped and if you eat shit on a cruise ship,
yeah,
you,
you're stuck with those people for seven days.
Well that's,
that's the problem.
And they keep coming up to your URL for you personally ruined our whole
vacation.
We're from Ohio.
We had never even seen the ocean.
You'll ruin debt.
And then they'll say,
here,
this is true.
You,
they'll say,
oh,
you stay on the ship.
No,
actually I swim next to the ship.
Then when we're 150 miles out in the shark infested water,
they scooped me up until a few stupid jokes.
Then they throw me overboard.
You know,
I got fired from a cruise ship
for the weirdest per religious joke.
And uh,
you know,
I said this,
this dumb joke about Mitt.
I like Mitt Romney because it's hard.
Being a Mormon in Massachusetts is always just me and met.
I thought I was Mormon.
My father kept saying,
you're a moron.
So silly little joke.
And they,
that's what they complained about you for that.
They complained about,
I never fit in any way with those cruise ships.
You know,
it's,
it's really good if you,
if you are an active alcoholic,
you'll knock.
It's wonderful.
Or if you're addicted to food.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
The lunch buffet,
the breakfast buffet,
the midnight buffet.
I know.
It's like you,
you go on,
you look like a normal human being.
You get off the ship,
you'll like waddling.
Yeah.
There's a lot buddy.
And they manufactured so fun.
It's like,
I love your warehouse here and everything,
and you know what I like about it's quiet.
You know,
there's a lot of these gyms,
sound,
sound and these cruise ships,
you can't even go to the pool without hearing eighties disco.
You know,
it's like this thing.
Have a good time.
If you're not having a good time,
there's something fucked up about you,
you know,
have a good time.
Well,
I think what they're trying to do,
activity,
give people something to fill their time with when they're stuck on a floating
vessel.
Yeah.
I'm not interested.
I mean,
I still love clubs.
I still enjoy going to clean.
You know,
what's great in a club.
I probably overstated the other one,
but I'll tell you what does shift this when people are there to see you,
that's good.
Yeah.
That's a nice thing because then you're actually able to make people feel good
and in service.
But I've always had the same problem,
Joe,
is
when people try to help you by heckling or whatever and they think,
you know,
this is the help or whatever.
I,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
you know,
you're a fighter.
You,
you feel that temporary come up,
you know,
when it comes up quick and you've got to,
you got to contain it and yakked and,
but like in real life,
I wouldn't want to know those people.
They,
yeah.
So every job has the timing.
Yeah.
And I just feel like,
you know,
you prepare this material and you've,
you've,
uh,
worked on it.
You want to give it to people.
Yeah.
But I'm not complaining.
I made my living out of this,
you know,
so I mean,
it's just,
you want to be realistic.
Like on somebody's kid asked you,
you know,
what is it like,
you know what,
you know,
an audience I hate is an open mic audience.
Why?
Cause the other comedians,
they're really tense.
You know what I mean?
The really fucking tense because they're thinking that it's like an audition,
right?
The nervous.
Yeah.
So you feel it in here,
you'd feel in the air man.
Yeah.
But if you can go up and be smooth,
I remember teddy bears are on going up at an open mic night.
There's another one.
I wonder,
stop too.
In comedy,
when Teddy was in his prime,
when I first started in 1988 the first night I ever went on,
Jonathan Katz was hosting it,
stitches and a teddy went on and did a set and I was like,
good Lord.
His fucking timing is material.
Everything was so sharp and so good.
It just seems so unattainable.
It seems so out of reach,
you know?
So that was the thing about open mic nights in Boston,
like pros would stop in it,
stop it and let you know how it really should
be gone.
While I was at the comedy store when Richard Pryor was working shit out and he'd
start on a Monday and he'd go up,
he'd bomb.
Didn't matter.
He's working the material.
A week later he had this unbelievable set.
Yeah,
I worked with George,
Carl and I worked with Rodney Dangerfield.
I work best part about being in this business for me is the people that I've
worked with.
Just meeting them and seeing them and seeing them,
seeing people great at what they do.
You know?
I'm sure you feel that way with the MMA,
whatever,
you know?
Sure.
Yeah,
we'll
comedy as well.
You know what I mean?
It's,
um,
it's been amazing watching people develop their acts and know and just to know
that that's,
that's a process that we all have to go through.
You know,
the,
the process of creating material,
it's never gets any easier.
It's always hard.
I mean,
to this day,
when you're working out new material,
it's probably weird.
Right.
It's funny that material seems to come to me and now it's,
I'm at that point where it just sort of events,
right?
It,
you know,
Bob Kraft and the whole thing and,
but here's what I don't like about,
this is sounding like a bitch session right now.
No.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
We're just talking shop.
Okay.
Uh,
what I don't like is it's Trump all day and then all the late nights shows it's
more Trump.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
There's no escape from this.
Well,
that's what they think people want to hear.
Yeah.
I don't think it's that creative though.
It gets a little tiresome.
Yeah.
I think especially after two years,
you got something really funny.
You say,
I always keep the door open.
Sometimes you got something really fun.
You say,
you never know.
You know the,
the INA here,
stormy Daniels is doing stand up now.
You know,
that's another thing.
People fucking,
you know what I mean?
It's probably a good five minutes of material if that.
And she's at,
you know,
they were guys,
um,
I think it was Richard Lewis and Dennis Miller and the couple of other guys came
through next and they didn't want to close.
You know,
they follow me.
Of course.
I've watched some of those sets.
And then I said,
uh,
one of them said,
you know,
I'm gonna can I middle?
I said,
sure that I'm going to get your money though,
right?
It's an all no.
I said,
well,
what the fuck?
Good headline.
Or you know,
well done.
I mean,
I followed,
uh,
Jay Leno at the,
at the Improv.
You know,
you kind of follow people.
Yeah,
you got to follow people.
But in all fairness,
uh,
what I used to see,
and I saw this many times at Nick's,
was some poor fuck who had like a couple of TV credits who thought he was hot
shit and they would go on and they would headline at Nick's and they would stack
the deck and it would be horrendous.
It was you and Lenny and fucking Knox and all these savages would go up and
Boston style comedy where there's no breaks.
It's just fucking Bang,
Bang.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
There's a style of comedy,
like a,
Hey,
I know you worked all day.
You don't want to hear anybody bullshit and up here.
But he talks fast and they're fucking funny.
And Gavin would go up and murder and then these poor bastards would go up after
them and just these people with their TV credits,
you would see them just be within five minutes,
they'd be lost.
It'd be very observational.
Have you ever gone to an airport or they just don't expect that they would see
three worldclass headliners do 15 minutes.
I'll tell you a funny story about next.
Sam Kennison,
right?
He,
you know,
he had been up for a few days obviously,
but anyway,
you know what I mean?
You know the era.
So I said [inaudible] and Sam was a good friend of mine.
He's a nice guy.
When he was straight,
he had a dark side,
you know,
like we all do.
But I said,
Sam,
this isn't,
this isn't la.
You know,
these guys,
you know Joey the job and bully the frond and fault can,
you know what I mean?
This sitting up front and he's,
you know how Sam was?
And I said,
Sam,
I'm telling you these are the wrong guys to piss off.
They had to fire him because you know those guys,
they'll kill it.
They don't,
they don't have any sense of humor.
No.
Well,
not only that,
you don't want to be fucked with.
Yeah.
Boston's.
So one of the weird,
some of the weirdest people in terms of like the way the rest of the world
works,
that they're ready to fight.
There's a lot of people that are ready to fight though,
ready to fight you.
They're not going to shoot you or stab you.
They're going to beat the fuck out of you,
right?
They're got to do it right then and there and it'll,
it'll happen anywhere.
And it'll happen at a restaurant or happen at a bar is one of the last places
that we,
when we used to towards him ready to break out what you would see real fist
fights like all the time.
Like Ari Shaffir used to say that like,
um,
me and him while we were leaving Faneuil hall once and there was a fucking bra
breaking out in front of this Mcdonald's and he's like,
you fucking people are savages here.
I'm like,
I'm telling you,
it's a different kind of human.
It's cold for too much.
The women are assholes.
Like it's the men are assholes.
Everybody's ready to fight and everyone's drunk to different kind of place.
Well,
you know the,
I grew up in Charleston,
right?
They did a movie about the town and all that bullshit.
It's a bullshit movie.
But anyway,
I grew up over there and you didn't have to win,
but you had a fight.
And my record was probably like two wins and 30 losses.
And then to,
you know,
there's a lot of draws because they break it up right away,
you know.
But there were actual fist fights.
Yeah.
No.
One time I'm in the projects is kid Davey ladder.
He did the one thing you're not supposed to do.
He kicked me in the balls and then everybody jumped and beat the shit out of
him.
One thing about kicking people in the balls to don't have a mess.
Yeah.
Cause then the other guy gets very mad.
It doesn't work as good as people think it does.
Really.
It hurts.
Now.
Were you in street fights?
I started fighting to avoid street fights.
I know I wanted to fight like as a,
as an amateur like in martial arts tournaments because I was scared of street
fights
seem to me,
it seemed to me to,
I'm frightened and he fucking terrifying.
You never know what's going to happen.
People follow you around.
You never know when it's going to.
I was scared of fighting.
That's why I got into it.
I was,
I just,
I did not like,
do you remember that day when you were in grammar school?
And a kid offers you out?
Yeah.
At eight 30 in the morning and still thinking about it all day early in the
morning till three in the afternoon.
What's that running down your pants.
Did you just shit yourself here and then you're in the school yard and they're
all circling around you,
you know,
and it's this whole thing.
But my father is to train fighters,
boxers over at the new guard and Jim and me and my brother,
we would get into terrible fights and my father never taught us how to throw a
shot or anything.
It just gives us these big,
enormous fricking gloves and they just let you go to war on each other.
Yeah,
it was weird.
Why did he teach you?
Probably tired from teaching people all day.
Yeah,
maybe.
it probably will.
Maybe he wanted us to beat the shit out of each other.
You know,
it,
I don't know.
That's a good question.
I'm not going to figure it out on your own.
Yeah.
Or it's,
you know,
I remember coming back and,
um,
this kid beat the shit out of me.
Bobby Buckley and my father said,
what are you doing at home?
You got to go back out there.
What?
I'm going to go back out and fight him against fucking all right.
Yeah.
But I,
you know,
there's a lot of different ways to be like in Charlestown grown up.
I mean,
I was,
I grew up with some guys that were like unbelievable.
Like,
you know,
there's a,
there's a whole moral thing maybe,
or a social thing about say robbing a bank.
I mean,
would that ever fricking cross your mind?
No,
but that's a Charlestown thing.
That's one thing that is true about that movie,
that town,
but,
but what I was in awe of people that would do it.
It's like,
where do you get the boss that you know?
And I'll never forget this friend of mine,
Joey Rocco's no longer with us.
So I see him up at government.
Sunbury remember government center?
Yeah.
So I see him up there and he's got like his lunch and um,
I said,
Joe,
how you doing?
And he's kind of blew me off.
Then I see him a week later.
He says,
Hey,
swings,
what's up?
I said,
You blew me off a week ago.
He said,
I'm so sorry.
I was waiting to Rob Crimson travel and I had my gun there and I was into cars
interrupting his work.
So he came into Nick's comedy stop to 400 people.
I did fantastic.
I was like practically a standing ovation,
whatever.
So Joe's in the audience,
right.
And I,
I,
so I talked to him afterwards.
So there's a number of things he could say like,
Jeez,
I liked his show.
I didn't like your show.
Good for you getting out of Charlestown.
He came at this look.
I was like,
wow,
it's got to be a lot of money in here.
I said,
you think I'm here to case the joint?
It was unbelievable.
We used to a part of the thing that bugged shots down growing up with see how to
shoplift that was,
did you do that when you were a kid?
Like I got caught shoplifting candy.
Yeah,
you were bad.
You probably was terrified.
Right?
Again,
I got brought into a manager's office,
I think it was 12 oh yeah,
I got in trouble.
I was terrible too.
I was so paranoid.
But anyway,
there was a department store called Jordan Marsh and my job was to catch a
football.
They'd throw me the football,
I'd catch it and run down Tremont street.
So we've just,
you know,
stolen a football.
Right.
So that's,
that was the Gig.
So one time I'm up there and
saw the kid says to me,
pick up the end of this [inaudible] I said,
what?
He said,
grab the end of the Cannula,
still in a fucking canoes.
What's all walking down?
Washington student Boston with a canoe right now.
I don't know where you're from,
but it's not a big item.
And Charlestown canoes and
the projects,
you know what I mean?
It's like not something you can,
you couldn't fence it.
Did you take it to the Charles River?
I don't know what we did with it.
Like you do try to,
you end up either giving it away or selling it for like three bucks.
And that was back then,
that the river was very,
very dirty.
Like I used to swim in that.
Oh,
that was the,
uh,
what we used to call the oilies because there was so much oil in it.
Yeah.
And better now though,
right?
Didn't they cleaned it up a little bit.
That's what they say.
You know,
they made,
they've cleaned up the whole of Boston.
I don't recognize boss anymore.
They got this pot of Boston called the sea port.
It's all these big buildings.
It's like fricking Dubai,
you know,
there's no kids,
there's no neighborhoods,
there's no characters.
It's all just gentrified and a very rich people now.
Right.
Yeah.
I apparently,
yeah.
What does it like bankers like who's got all that money?
I,
that's what I keep asking myself.
Who does have all this money?
Yeah.
Boston is definitely,
but la is the same way,
you know?
Yeah.
All,
it's all money.
Yeah.
But there's normal neighborhoods in la.
Look around here.
Like you could like woodland hills,
like wander round West hills,
like,
yeah,
studio city.
There's normal neighborhoods as regular houses.
There's plenty of what,
you know,
normal spots.
What I've noticed though is I was in Portland,
Oregon and there was a whole like city of homeless people.
Yeah.
In La there's just sparklies like Jimmy's on top of an ice cream,
you know,
you got to go to skid row skid,
you'd never seen anything like it.
Skim Rosa homeless city.
It's insane.
There's thousands of homeless people wandering through the streets.
They,
they've taken over entire neighborhoods.
Like it is,
it is bizarre.
It's bizarre.
We used to film fear factor downtown.
We would a film it at these abandoned warehouses.
They would rent them out and we'd,
you know,
throw people off the roof and shit.
And uh,
we,
there was this one area where you would go where,
and I'm not exaggerating,
there might be a thousand people on this block,
like a concert just let out.
Like they were having a homeless concert and they're all just wandering around.
There's needles everywhere and tents and garbage in the streets and,
and people just shuffling around,
walking back and forth.
So there's,
I guess there's some homeless centers,
you know,
where people can go and get food and things and shelter.
You know,
I'm starting to wonder like what's wrong with me with you because I seem to
focus on that.
You know,
every city I go to I say,
wow.
It seems like there's more and more homeless people and other people are saying,
oh,
let's go to the freedom trail.
Let's,
let's look at the beauty of San Francisco.
Look,
I shitting on the street.
To me that's like unusual.
San Francisco has a app where you could find where the people are shitting.
They have not jokes.
Right.
Hold it up before.
Yeah.
There's so many people shitting in San Francisco on the street San,
I'm my friend Jake shields got a photo of this guy taking his shit right in
front of them.
Just shit spraying out of his ass.
Went under the street from the sidewalk into the street.
No,
I don't know what I mean.
They just do it in front of everybody.
I don't know why people,
you know who's sick or the person with the APP with a guy taking a dump.
Well,
I think there's a certain open mindedness that San Francisco has a lot of very
progressive open minded people.
Which is good,
but the problem is it opens the door for some ridiculous stuff like people
shitting on the street.
There's too many homeless people too.
They're too open minded and to liberal.
Look at that.
That's the,
that's the shit map.
That's where all the people are shooting.
That's a dark puddle of shed where so many people were shitting on the street in
that area and I don't even know how they cleaned that up.
I mean,
what do they do?
They scrape it hose a street down.
Is that an extra,
is that,
are they creating jobs?
Let's look at it on the positive side.
God,
maybe those homeless people reminds me of the parades when they,
to the horses.
There's nothing you could do either.
I mean,
what are you going to do?
Are you going to give these people a place to live?
You got to give these people food.
You going to give these people money.
There's,
it's not going to fix their mental illness.
That's what people don't understand about a lot of these folks.
It's not that they run on bad luck,
that's they're not on bad luck.
They're mentally ill,
they have,
their brain's not working correctly and if they don't want to be on medication
and they don't have any way to turn,
they don't have anywhere to go,
they're going to stay there and they don't have anywhere to shit.
And you know,
they just want to use this tree.
And I don't know if they could put up Porta potties and say for homeless folks
only and what can they do?
We're not going to solve that on the Joe Rogan show.
I'm an optimistic person,
stays with the,
you never know.
I was thinking of myself,
he just,
you know,
just shitting your pants.
Um,
so anyway,
we've covered that.
What else is the problem that we have in this country?
This is one,
a lot of the Pr,
I always look at it,
everybody's so pissed off in this country because everything's going well,
so much going well in terms of the economy,
in terms of safety,
in terms of that cause.
So people are focusing on other things to be mad at when you away from war to,
you know,
like you know when,
when when you don't have to worry about as much violence.
People concentrate on microaggressions.
That's one of the things.
It does happen.
There's definitely problems in this country for sure,
but I think that part of the outrage is that people are,
it's recreational.
They're looking to be outraged about things because there's no real problems.
Wow.
When there's real problems,
people focus on,
you know,
when there's,
you have to really worry about violence or you have to really worry about
health.
People focus on,
on,
you know,
the good things in life.
People are only happy if they have a certain amount of adversity that they have
to deal with when there's less and less adversity,
I find,
I find that people become more and more outraged and easier.
They're outraged.
It's small minor details or the denying that people should be allowed to just
fuck up and make some mistakes here
and there.
They,
they concentrate on those mistakes.
Like it's the end of the world.
This person should be ostracized from society and kicked out.
And this is the end.
Well,
going back to politics,
if you get into discussion with somebody you agree with [inaudible],
you still end up being pissed off because you're pissed off at the other side.
Or the other political thing is you're angry at each other for different points
of view.
Yup.
But I always think to myself
as I'm sure you do,
it's an amazing place to be.
We have enough food.
We have enough water.
I myself,
I think life is two things.
Life is a gift and life is short,
you know,
and the purpose of life,
my opinion is to develop whatever talents you have and then share it.
So I couldn't agree more.
What,
what a,
what a place to do it.
[inaudible]
place in the world to do it.
You'll have the opportunity,
you know,
and uh,
but you know,
it's like we,
I think we do tend to complicate things.
What I don't like is when we let other things get between us as human beings,
because it's,
it's a whole,
that's why I like Buddhism,
for example,
because you're never going to see outside of rare exceptions,
a Buddhist country is never going to win bait and other country because the
whole principle is mindfulness.
In other words,
it's all within you,
so you don't have to push your beliefs on other people.
Like I have a lot of friends who become Christians,
which is great for them,
but they always put you on a,
I always feel like I've put in a box.
Yeah.
Like have you accepted Jesus?
You know how the fuck you gonna answer that.
You know what I mean?
I'm not yet see,
not yet.
Keep,
keep conveys it's on the way.
Yeah,
that's right.
It's like one of those unanswerable things,
you know?
Well,
it's also a thing where people can hold Muslims,
Christians,
it seems like they,
they believe that,
you know,
people have to hear this great message and if they don't hear it,
shove it down your fucking throat.
I think half of them don't even think you have to hear it.
They just want to have it over you,
that Dave,
they've accepted Jesus into their life and you haven't,
so they win.
There's a lot of that.
I mean,
you see so many hypocritical Christians that don't really follow,
turn the other cheek.
They don't really treat everyone as if it's their brother.
They don't really do that.
They don't really,
they don't really feel that way.
They're not,
they're not out there.
Well that's cause that's,
that that standard is like,
you're going to be Jesus.
Right.
You know,
I mean,
Jesus Christ.
you know what I mean?
No Pun intended,
but who's cooking live up to that?
So if someone can,
but so there's people,
there aren't,
no,
I got people that processize anything.
It's like,
it's very,
uh,
you know,
it's like,
why doesn't get away from me?
Yeah.
Well,
it's a,
it's a shitty psychological tactic.
Doesn't work.
Yeah.
It's just makes people,
it's,
we talk about,
it's like when you try to get people to do things,
they're less likely to do those things as soon as you are angry at them,
but they're not doing it,
they're going to go the other way.
People don't like being told what to do.
Well,
it's just like if somebody wants to get sober,
right.
Right.
If you,
if they are ready.
I work in jail.
That's one of my part time jobs.
So what are you doing?
Jails.
I do substance abuse stuff in jails.
So if you,
um,
if they're ready,
everything you say you're like a guru.
If they're not ready,
it doesn't matter what you say.
Right.
So I do groups in jail.
I teach meditation.
I also teach a goal setting.
I've been doing it about six years.
I've been in the field of substance abuse for awhile.
And um,
it's very rewarding.
It's not,
you know,
you don't make any money,
but it balances the life.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't want to sit around all day.
Most comedians,
that's what they have to do.
You know,
they work at night.
So yeah.
I work at Plymouth jail.
How often you do it?
Uh,
two or three days a week.
Yeah.
That's good.
So it's not,
not every day now.
And I take the summers off too because it's intense.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I've had groups,
you know,
I had one guy,
he came in and you'd do it.
You'd do divide people,
ethnically white guy,
but six,
six big fucking,
you know,
did state time.
It was all jacked and he's wired.
And uh,
he started complaining about the place and uh,
I said,
hey,
this isn't,
I teach them to breathe,
you know,
like that guy hops you had on your show.
But I teach them a different method.
It's just you breathe in for,
you,
hold it for you,
let it out.
It's just a calming breath.
So anyway,
this guy,
I said,
hey,
it's places in a hotel.
He stands over.
He says,
yeah,
I know.
It's not how I said,
let's do our breathing.
Let's relax.
But a lot of guys,
they can't see,
they can't see themselves.
They can't see contradictions.
I,
one guy,
he was,
it was a Muslim,
right?
So I said,
so you guys pray like five times a day.
How do you know when to pray and listen to this Joe?
He says,
uh,
the guys said,
well,
if I'm doing a heist in the afternoon,
you know I'm gonna miss that prayer.
You don't see any contract can amazing the guy,
the big giant guy that was angry or did he have a certain amount of time before
he got out or was he in it for life?
No,
no,
he was,
he was on his way out.
He was coming close.
That's when guys get the most anxious.
How long have you been in four.
He was in for about 17 years.
It's a very polite society.
Really?
Prison society.
Society's very polite because every little thing,
just picture your,
you're trapped with all these other guys and a lot of mental health.
She had a lot of stuff,
but every little thing has picked up on and reacted to,
you know,
it's like that scene in heat between Dinero Pachino where they're just reacting
to each other.
So you said,
can you please pass the salt?
Pass it because at any minute,
that's what I tried to teach us.
It's about impulse control.
Any minute.
And I think it happened.
Yeah.
You know.
Well,
you know,
you're dealing with a bunch of very impulsive people that also have a very short
fuse there.
There used to violence.
Wow.
This is one way of acting out.
So what I say to them is,
I have the same thing,
but it's not through violence.
For me,
it's like texting or something,
you know,
I react or I drank,
so it's,
it's about stepping back.
Dang Gum.
Yeah.
It's hard when you get tripped up,
but the mind listens to the breath.
That's the key.
Rather than going up in your mind,
take that breath and you know,
like when something's happening,
like a car crash or something.
First impulses,
hold your breath.
Don't hold your breath,
let your breath out.
I mean,
a lot of traditions have this,
you know,
Tai Chi,
[inaudible] Yoga.
So yeah,
breathing is critical.
It's everything.
When Wim Hoff teaches it,
you know,
if you follow those methods,
you can,
you can really change your physiological state.
You can,
you can get out of a lot of things.
It can get you through a lot of things.
You know the thing that I don't buy those,
that fucking cold water.
I don't want to go onto the Arctic like him.
Holy Shit.
It's because you live in Boston.
You get God algae to call it.
My friend Mark Grata.
He's ready to go.
He's done.
He's been there for too long.
I know a lot about this weekend.
A lot of people they get like that,
but it hit the wall,
you know the,
I think two of the most boring subjects on earth or like how cold it is and how
wonderful the weather is out here.
And then the other one is how someone lost weight.
You know,
I look at them like,
what makes you think I give a fuck how you lost this weight?
And then the last me how somebody else lost weight.
Like frank sent Raleigh lost weight and he wanted to tell him it's,
yeah frank,
this isn't,
this is a car.
We'd have to talk about something with more substance.
And then people will say to me,
how did Lenny Clarke lose weight?
It's like,
I don't give a shit how he lost weight.
You know,
I'm a self centered fucking comedian anyway.
You know
the good thing about cold weather though is it teaches people character.
The people out here that have never had to deal with an earthquake,
they don't know any weather related nature related hazards.
If you stay here,
it just stays warm and then it gets a little cool and it stays warm.
I spent one winter out here that I was,
it was horrible.
I was trying to get sitcoms and never getting anything and it rained every day
and it was,
it was horrible.
And I was staying in one of these corporate apartments that you woulds garden.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but,
but it was initially the cheaper version and the guy next door was from Jamaica
and it was on the phone all fucking night.
He said,
this is the only time I can talk to her.
It's got to be this time of night.
I'm telling you,
man,
it's real important.
I remind them,
Bang,
now it's gone.
Yeah.
How long you been out here?
Since 94 Oh,
you've been out here a while.
Forever.
I've been here more than anywhere else in my life,
but that's my observation.
Grew up in Newton,
didn't you?
Well,
I lived there from,
I lived in Jamaica plain from I guess 13 to,
yeah,
13 to 14.
I lived there for a year and then I lived in Newton from 14 to 20.
And then,
uh,
then I lived in revere and I lived in Saugus for awhile.
No,
you got to,
you got a reputation for what?
It's a good reputation.
Oh,
that's good.
Yeah.
What did I do?
Well,
it's just what we were just talking about.
You have a reputation as a bad ass.
Oh,
that reputation.
Yeah.
That's a good thing.
It's mostly bullshit it,
well,
you had Tyson on.
Yeah.
And it was interesting that he didn't want to go back to it.
Do you know Marvin Hagler has the same problem?
Oh yeah.
Well,
he was the only guy that ever just quit at the top.
But he won't,
he won't punch a bag or anything because that thing comes up in him where he,
he wants to do it again.
It's like an addiction and he's gotta be 60 now.
It's still wow.
The welling
up inside of him.
I respect him so much.
You know,
I always looked up to him when I was fighting cause uh,
I remember the discipline that that guy had.
Like I remember watching videos of him and he was a living on the cape.
He would treat you as Trump camp in the cape and he would run and he's running
from Sam boots.
Yeah.
Combat boots on.
And he was,
it was yelling war.
He was like getting ready to fight Mustapha Hamshaw show and he's running and
shadow boxing is yelling war.
And I'm like,
I'm just thinking,
could you imagine if you had a fight that fucking guy,
when he was the middle weight champion of the world,
first of all,
he was chiseled.
Like it was sculpted out of bronze.
They didn't even look like a,
I mean he was,
he was so jacked for a boxer.
When you think about like most boxers,
they didn't have that kind of physique.
His physique was like almost like a gymnast,
you know,
when he was in his prime and he just was so disciplined and forth and then beat
the fuck out of everybody and then lost that one.
Very controversial fight to sugar that I was at the fight and then he was like,
that's it.
See Ya.
I've had enough.
Went to Italy.
He came a fucking movie star,
which is crazy.
He said,
apparently,
I mean I've never seen an Italian movie with Ma Marvelous Marvin Hagler in it.
Nobody has,
I think they,
I think Natalie,
I think it's a myth is it might be a myth or true or no.
Can you see [inaudible] what's
the rumor was always that he threw the fight with Leonard that he could Kale
Leonard,
but he did.
All he had to do is let Len and go to a decision.
He would lose that decision.
They pay him a boatload of cash and he goes to Italy.
What does it you Marvin Hagler and a movie.
I remember seeing that Jesus Christ,
oh,
that's a long time ago because he looks really young back.
Oh my God,
he is Nyo.
No one's ever seen those movies.
Wow.
So this is an Italian,
but well,
you know they made all those Spaghetti Westerns when they did all those movies
in Italy.
Oh my God.
Isn't that something?
Those movies,
those job look at you look at,
he's shooting everybody.
Oh yeah.
This is an action star.
I wonder while he's still jacked in that movie.
So it must have been doing some kind of exercising.
Look good.
I'm all good.
Oh God.
He's fuck Jesus Christ through the air.
So India,
it looks like,
oh,
this is so hilarious.
This is so hilarious.
So now get to know,
you know me know when you do a movie and the guy hits you,
you're supposed to move your head so that he's not actually hitting you.
And I hope Marvin knew that.
I'm sure he had because he,
yeah,
thank God I pulled the punch.
I did a movie in Boston called southy with a guy throws me in a dumpster and
kills me.
Right.
And they had to do it over and over and the guy just got out of Walpole to state
penitentiary.
I'm not gonna mention his name,
but he's,
he's the director now out here as a matter of fact.
And I said,
Hey,
do you know this is a fucking movie?
He'd fire in the fight.
You know the shot that the starter's pistol and he kept throwing me over.
That guy is in everything.
Brian Dennehy was 1989 90 oh one so 89 was probably just a few years after he
retired.
He retired somewhere around 86 87 when did he fight Leonard?
What an error that was.
Oh,
it was amazing.
We used to watch,
maybe you must've closed circuit fights.
We'd go to a theater and you'd watch it on a big screen.
Closer to tell you how many,
I got so ripped off because you had Tyson on.
I remember driving,
I was out here to go to this big fight,
50 bucks,
and I walked in and Tyson knock them out in the first round.
That was all that ever happened.
People were trying to figure out what he was amazing.
Yeah,
yeah.
But it was a,
it's what it was seven e seven interesting,
Huh?
Yeah.
And that was it.
He's like,
I'm done.
So that was only two years after he retired.
He was doing movies,
but the best John the beast Mugabi but Marvin Hagler versus John the beast.
Ivan have hair from a Gabi.
No,
I remember seeing Martin with Harris.
The gardens wives.
Yeah.
Did he grow it out for a goof?
No,
he had a,
Harley has created a really fucking hard,
he had an extra inch of scholar or something.
They were saying no,
it was the side temples,
giant temple muscles.
They said he was almost like bill with that Mugabe and Mugabe was a murderous,
that's Thomas Hearns boy Thomas Thomas.
That's Mugabi for sure.
Mugabi.
He hit Marvin Hagler with an uppercut and snapped his head back and this is an
uppercut that he was knocking everybody out.
But Non Marvin Marvin took a punch better than anybody.
He said the fight only started when I started the band.
I think one role,
Dan was the only guy that ever knocked Marvin down,
but it wasn't a real knockdown.
It was a trip and they counted that as a knocked down.
Oh,
he was a tremendous fighter.
But I know inside,
look at how it gets into the PSOAS.
Mugabe.
Mugabe was a murderer.
It's punching until he was knocking everybody out.
He knocked out Terry Norris.
He knocked,
he knocked people out dead like you would hit them and they would go flying,
but not Marvin.
Marvin stood right in front of them and eventually k Odom,
and then Mugabi was never the same again.
Once you realize that this mother fucker could stand right in front of them to
shut up,
what does this referee stop?
What is he doing?
I don't know what's going on there.
That's mills lane.
Hey,
now that we have a break in the action,
I'd like to,
I'd like to plug my movies.
Sweeney killing Sweeney.
Yeah,
middle of the march.
We talked about it.
It's coming out.
I want to plug it again.
Well tool cause it's login.
We'll plug the shit out of it.
All right.
When it comes out,
we'll put it on Twitter.
Right Buddy.
But appreciate that.
But he was that guy.
Marvin Hagler was to me like he was the epitome of discipline,
you know,
and I thought about like a discipline fighter who was him always in shape,
always ready to go.
And then the discipline to never come back.
That was amazing too.
To me.
I've respected the fuck out of that because fighters never know when to when to
leave.
He knew when to leave.
And to this day I saw him in an interview recently.
He's fine.
Talk completely normal.
I had some chowder with him at the Prudential Center.
How long?
How often,
how long ago rather than maybe a year ago.
He's a regular,
very regular guy.
Yeah.
Like no,
no brain damage.
No,
no slurring her words.
Yeah,
that's,
that's amazing.
When a fight,
it can figure out how to get out before all that stuff hits.
But you know how they feel.
They feel like no one else should tell him when to quit.
Oh,
of course.
Have you had Mickey Rourke on this show?
No,
I haven't.
Yeah,
I would though because I think that I read he was fighting at 57 in Russia or
older than that.
Really?
He was 62,
I think he was 62 and he had his last fight and he might've been a fake fight.
Oh really?
I'm not gonna lie to you.
It looks like maybe Mickey tone.
It was real.
And the gentleman,
he was fighting with the six 66,
he was 66 and he was in a box in [inaudible] 66 now,
I believe he was 62 or 63 when he hit his last altercation inside the rail,
fighting boxing gyms.
The old ones were fun to hang around.
I remember I was sitting there with these five guys and uh,
we were talking about some election and they weren't saying anything and that
the guy said,
do you realize that we're all convicted felons?
Like why you talking to us about who to vote for?
You know what I mean?
Is that him now?
That's Micky.
Wow.
Look at him.
That's the last year looking good for 65.
It looks like he's at some sort of a homeless shelter or something.
Where's he getting his clothes there?
He's got no shirt on in Rome,
I think somewhere in Rome.
I just saw something with him and he was doing,
uh,
he was walking in a fashion show.
Yeah.
I've seen him at the UFC is before.
He's always there saying hi.
He's a nice guy and very good shape for his age,
you know?
I mean,
he,
yeah.
Used to spar with James Toney.
He's too,
uh,
like one of the things that he did that was probably very questionable was when
he was at the height of his movie career.
He decided to stop and become a professional boxer later.
But I think he was a fighter before he was an act.
He was.
But when he stopped down in Miami,
I think he kind of felt like acting was fake and then he needed something real
in his life.
So he's going to have some professional fights.
But apparently that's why he started getting all that plastic surgery fucked his
face up.
His face was smashed.
And you are an amateur and I,
no,
MMA,
kickboxing and taekwondo.
There was no a MMA when I was fighting.
It didn't exist yet.
At least not in America.
Wow.
I didn't find out about Himalayan until like being in the ring.
Kickbox is nerve wracking.
The thing about it too is there's no money in it.
You know,
like you're fighting for free and you're,
you know,
you're training for months or weeks or however long it is for this that you
have.
You're,
you're constantly sparring.
You're constantly getting kicked and punched.
It's,
uh,
it's terrible for you,
but it's a good thing to learn.
I think it's a very important thing to learn,
to know how to fight is a very good thing.
But to fight,
he got to know,
unless you're doing it professionally,
you gotta know when to stop.
He got to know when I started getting a lot of headaches.
Yeah,
it was,
I was sparring.
But that's one thing about Boston,
like we're talking about Boston,
you know,
Boston audiences are hard.
Boston sparrings hard boss,
Boston fighters,
they fought.
There's not a lot of like technical sparring.
Like when you tactically spar with somebody,
like if you hit him,
you hit him like this.
You don't,
you don't hit him full blast,
you know,
you tap each other.
So you know,
like where you making mistakes.
There was none of that.
It was just swing for the bleachers every fucking like that,
that I still go to.
What I love is the golden gloves.
Oh yeah.
I mean it's all action.
Three rounds.
Three types of competition when I'm talking about is training the real beatings.
He take her in the Cim,
the beatings that nobody ever see.
You know?
And you know what's amazing is that this friend of mine,
Jimmy Feral,
had a gym in Quinsy.
And I look at these guys and I say,
wow,
this guy's amazing.
He said,
that guy's record,
it's five wins and 13 losses.
And I said,
well,
that guy,
I mean,
that's how good you have to be.
These guys are like this.
There's no,
well also some inch,
they're inconsistent.
Like a lot of fighters are very impulsive people.
So they're often inconsistent.
Like they'll get in shape for a few fights and then a few other fights I'll fuck
off.
They drink too much,
they party and then they go in and ring and they lose and they lose a close
decision or lose,
uh,
lose a war.
Isn't it?
A lot of it about style too.
Sure.
Yeah.
My favorite fighters ever,
uh,
from a boxing point of view was Ali and Frazier because,
well,
for one thing it was a fight to the death,
right?
I mean,
they literally were fighting all three times to the death.
But Joe Frazier was an inside fighter and he was so low.
And then I'll leave with,
stay away from him and just jab.
And it was just a beautiful exhibition of fighting styles inside fighting.
And outside fighting.
Anybody listening to this that is interested in this shit,
they are believing in that left hook that Joe Frazier Aaa in this hundred
percent the left took Joe Frazier Drop Muhammad Ali with when he won the title,
when he,
when he beat him,
when the Ali's comeback and that was like,
Whoa,
this is one of the greatest punches of all time.
One of the most epic,
but one of them.
Yeah,
I mean just swung that wild left,
took and clipped and Ryan the Chin and dropped him.
It's one of the most iconic photos of all time is Joe Frazier leaping through
the air,
landing that left hook on the jaw of Ali and Ali going down.
I'm going to go back.
Okay,
what are you going to do?
There was a guy named Floyd Patterson.
Sure.
Who had that.
He lost the Sonny Liston,
Sonny Liston.
I'm just reading about Sonny Liston.
Sonny Liston was a murderer.
Sonny Liston was one of 25 kids.
He was his mother,
you know,
whatever.
It's fine.
Was like a sharecropper and he got involved in gangs and all this and I'm
one of those guys,
you know,
I think he ended his career,
that shot or something to died.
No,
she died of a drug overdose or I'll go over it.
I think he ended his career as a,
like a bouncer in Vegas.
Yeah.
You know,
like a doorman or something like that.
Right.
Casino one of those,
one of those guys like Joe Louis,
whatever.
Yeah.
Those big guys that ended up,
yeah.
You know,
it's a funny,
funny sport.
Do you ever watch that fight with him in Floyd Patterson?
Uh,
not that one.
Oh yeah.
I think I may have terrifying,
but I remember when,
uh,
I'm old enough to remember when Cassius clay beats on him.
Beat him twice.
He was like eight to one.
That was another fight where a lot of people thought it was fixed.
The second fight,
the second one in Lewiston,
Maine and hit punch well was that you could see the punched it said,
they said to call it a phantom punch.
You can see the punch,
but it was like a,
he called it an anchor punch cause it's like as listing was coming forward,
he dropped it down on him like that and a lot of people say it didn't land but
you could see his head react.
It definitely landed.
The question was whether or not he decided to stay down and once he got hit,
I think he did.
If you watch it just doesn't look realistic.
I can be watched when he goes down the way he went down scene.
Maybe legit,
but the way stumbled around it.
He didn't stumble around like a guy who his central nervous system got jacked.
Here we go.
Watch it right here.
Oh,
what a great producer.
You the best.
Watch this.
I'll get this pink.
See that's a real punch.
100% and the Dra,
the him dropping is real too.
There's no doubt about it.
The question was whether that was enough to take them out.
Look at that bank.
It could have,
but watch the case.
See if you can find the knockout Jamie because the what's not,
what's crazy about it wasn't him dropping him cause I think that was legit.
What's crazy was how afterwards he stumbled around like he couldn't move.
He couldn't get up.
It just didn't seem real.
What'd we just had it there for a long explanation.
I don't know if they're going to show the actual thing.
Well then they just showed him trying to get up.
That kinda looks like Kevin Spacey.
Oh zero.
That was the actual,
wow,
here it is.
Here it is.
Play it.
Watch,
here's the punch.
Boom.
Now Watch.
He goes down and he just sort of laid down on his back
and then he kind of stumbled around and acted like he couldn't get up.
They just keep showing it over and over again.
It was 100% of legitimate punch and people who say it's not,
they've never seen people get chaos cause people get Kol and all sorts of weird
ways.
It doesn't really make sense.
Like it's a human being getting punched in the face.
Weird Shit happens.
Especially,
you get punched on the jaw,
like see,
people get touched with like a jab.
Sometimes when they go out it doesn't make sense.
And it also,
sometimes here it is,
it's right here.
It's also sometimes it's weird because you might've gotten hurt real bad and
training.
So a lot of guys come in to these fights and they're already injured.
They just boom right there.
Now let's watch them stumble around.
So he goes down and he lays down on his back seat.
This is where I'm not buying it.
This si just seems like Horse Shit.
But I could be wrong.
Now he's stumbling.
See like right there,
that seemed like he decided to stumble and go down and he's trying to get back
up.
I could be wrong,
but I'm not buying it.
Okay.
And so,
uh,
the referee was jersey,
Joe Walcott,
who's a very famous champion of his own.
Now they started way by,
no,
did they stop the fight?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
Well,
you know the first fight,
fifth round,
I think it was list and put some white stuff on his gloves.
Yeah.
And he blinded.
This is how crooked the game was he playing that?
Ali Cassius clay.
So listen wasn't above,
you know,
cheating.
Yeah.
Do you remember that fighter?
Oh my God,
this is so frightening.
He w he wrapped something in his Louie.
Yeah,
Billy Junior.
No,
he took all the padding Adam's gloves back in the day.
The day you still use horse hair with the gloves and you could,
you could put a little hole in the gloves and pull the padding out.
And uh,
Louie Resto,
Panama Lewis was his trainer and Panama Lewis was also the same guy that gave a
Aaron Pryor that little a jab cocaine right before he knocked out Alexis
Arguayo.
I mean they think it was cocaine.
He said gimme the other bottle,
the one that I prepared,
he gives it to Aaron Pryor.
And then Aaron Pryor goes out and starches,
Alexis Arguayo,
they had a crazy war of a fight and then he gives him something in this little
bottle.
And then Aaron Pryor goes out like a bat out of hell.
And once the question was always what was in that bottle,
cause there was no sophisticated drug testing back then,
but Panama Louis,
but there was one of them that actually put cement or something in their gloves.
Um,
there was that,
that was a more recent one that was a,
that Mexican gentleman that fought,
uh,
what,
did he do that too?
That the red hand?
No,
no,
no.
He doesn't isn't fight anymore.
Fuck I'm drawing a blank on his name.
But he,
he beat up some really prominent fighters that way.
How the fuck did he,
there was a one fight in particular,
boy,
I'm seeing the guy in my face.
Yes.
Antonio Margarito who pull,
pull up his record because he did it to,
uh,
he did it to some like legit fighters and uh,
really beat them up and they were like,
it didn't even make sense how hard he was hitting me.
Cause he,
he would put plaster of Paris apparently inside the wraps and Miguel Cotto.
That's who it was.
Right.
And then Miguel Cotto beat the shit out of him.
The rematch and Shane Mosley,
sugar Shane Mosley beat the fuck out of him when they found this seat.
After he knocked out Miguel Cotto,
we beat him up in the 11th round.
He stopped him and it was a horrible stop.
It's too,
he beat the shit out of him.
Then the Shane Mosley fight was the fight that he lost.
That was the next fight.
During the wrapping of the gloves,
Shane Mosley's camp was go,
what the fuck is in his raps?
They recognized it and it had a rewrap his hands.
And then Shane Mosley beat his fucking ass.
And then he'd beat Robert Garcia and then Manny Pacquiao fucked him up.
And then Miguel Cotto fucked him up.
Um,
but the Miguel Cotto fight,
the first one,
it was,
it was bad.
I mean,
his face was busted up and,
and that's when people had suspicions,
but they didn't know until they saw the wrapping of the gloves.
And then they looked at every one of his fights before that,
and they will go,
oh,
this motherfucker had pledged
that city fat city.
Stacy Keach.
It's about club fighters down at Stockton one,
you know,
fantastic movie.
I don't think I've ever seen bridges first movies and John used and directed it.
One of the best fight movies ever.
This fight that I was talking about earlier,
the Louie Resto fight,
this Billy Collins junior guy was a,
he was an up and coming contender and he was blinded in the fight and could
never fight again.
Wow.
This kid that he fought,
Louie Resto,
they pulled all the padding out of the gloves and he just fucked up this guy's
face to the point where you know he had detached retinas and he couldn't see
straight and became an alcoholic afterwards.
When when your is right there look at his face.
Wow.
Yeah,
and it became a a a really big,
a big store salt with a deadly weapon
I think at the end of the other guys live for it.
At some point he admitted that he did it.
There was some documentary about it that the guide finally admitted that he was
using.
People have done that forever.
People who've done that forever.
I was sparring with a guy once and I went to touch his gloves and I was like,
what the fuck is and your gloves and is padding had all been,
it was those old style old style boxing gloves,
the padding you all push back and it was like,
it was all like almost raw knuckle people are assholes.
Yeah,
I've,
I've experienced that before.
What's interesting now is that people are actually fighting bare knuckle.
There's a whole bare knuckle boxing organization out of Wyoming.
You have all your knuckles?
Yeah,
they're all there.
There've been one broken out.
One that was broken.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Moves Weird cliques.
That was Bobby sell these knows
blobby Salvey is there a more fucking Boston named Bobby [inaudible].
Bobby Salvey.
I fucking hit him.
What a fucking over hand fucking left.
He fuck.
I went down like I'm gonna you know it's good to is the rap,
you know the guy's gonna fight,
you know like wrap it the end.
Well,
no,
it's,
I used to beat guys like you up on the way to a fight.
Practice fall on asshole.
You know that shit.
I like that.
Just like in basketball,
you know,
the,
the trash talk trash and yeah,
sometimes it works because the thing about when someone gets inside your head,
someone's really mean that.
I was kinda thinking that when you see listing and I'll leave,
right?
Yeah.
How could,
like,
it looked like listen was like afraid of him.
How could he be?
Well,
you know,
the reason why,
and this is Ali did this on purpose.
He acted like a crazy person because he's like that Sonny Liston was a bully and
Sonny Liston was a big scary man.
And what he felt like sunny lifts it would be afraid of,
it's a crazy person.
Someone who was afraid of him.
So when all the press conferences and all the different things leading up to the
fight,
he would scream at them.
He would show up at Sonny Liston,
his house and Honk the horn in the middle of the night and get on his lawn and
scream and yell at him.
Like he did a lot of crazy shit to Sonny Liston to fuck with them
psychologically.
He wanted something.
He did it.
He did it psychologically did he wanted Sonny Liston to think that he was a
crazy person and that you know,
that he would never stop.
And that's,
I mean he essentially did it and there was one point in time when they were,
um,
see we just let me hear some of this.
He,
he laid him,
he let them know he wasn't scared of him and they were doing his blood pressure
and his blood pressure was so high as Harvard,
it was so high they weren't going to let them find their like,
oh no,
Ali's,
he had a calm itself down cause he got himself worked up into a lather.
He was just so,
so angry.
And so,
you know,
so hyped up,
trying to act like a crazy person than when they were doing is pre-fight
medicals.
They were like,
hey,
you know,
like you can't fight your fucking,
there's something wrong with you.
And they had this,
here it is,
the calming him down.
He had to relax and calm down.
I don't know,
greatest,
greatest of all time.
I beat him all.
He was just so,
so smart at like psychological warfare.
There'd never been any anybody like him psychologically that could just,
he would,
he,
first of all,
he was very funny.
He would say hilarious shit.
Like Howard Cosell said to them,
tramp it champion seem very trucky let and he goes,
whatever truculent is,
if it's good on that.
That's right.
The timing was just perfect.
He was so,
he would,
you know,
say things that were funny.
He would say poetry.
He had that Guy Bundini Brown behind him and they were always,
you know,
there were always like laughing and joking around together.
Like he had a tremendous support team and on top of that he could fight his
fucking ass off.
And he was a heavyweight that moved around like a middleweight.
Unbelievable.
I mean he was a 200 plus pound,
215 220 pound man.
And he would shuffle and move and Bob and weave and he would be out there almost
like a Welsh.
We think he's the greatest.
He's a boy.
It's hard to say who's the greatest heavyweight of all time,
but he's certainly in the conversation.
I mean,
you would have to say how would he have done against some of the bigger,
stronger guys have of the past,
like a Lennox Lewis who,
uh,
you know,
was in his prime in the high 240 pound range.
She was a much bigger,
much bigger guy.
But no,
there was nobody like,
see Holly also comes in two stages.
There's Ali before 1967 when they took his license away.
And this is Ali.
After 1970 when he came back and when he came back,
he was never as fast.
He was never as fleet of foot cause he didn't work out at all for three years.
He didn't do shit.
No.
And when he came back,
his return fight,
um,
uh,
he just didn't look right.
He didn't look like he had the same movement.
His body didn't have the same musculature.
He just,
uh,
he fought.
Um,
Jerry,
no,
it wasn't Jerry Jerry Quarry.
That's how it was.
And he beat him.
He beat him up,
but he just didn't look like them.
The homily that fought like go to boxing matches.
Yeah.
I'll still go a box of matches.
I love watching on TV.
Yeah.
I don't,
I try not to go too many live events anymore cause I go to so many of them with
the UFC.
Yeah.
You know,
it's hard for me to go and do,
you know,
go,
go see more of them live.
But I do enjoy them.
You know,
it's nothing like being ringside for a,
um,
golden gloves.
Have you ever been to a UFC fight?
No.
Well,
you come,
I'll get you tickets.
Sure.
Next time we're in Boston I'll hook it up.
We go to Boston almost every year.
Okay.
Yeah.
I love it.
Some big fights together in Boston.
Yeah.
I want you to go.
It's crazy.
It's wild to see it live.
I get you get your right there on the floor right in front of the cage to
amazing.
Yeah.
Something,
something unique.
He'll be a good date.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's way wilder,
like when you get used to watching the UFC,
sometimes it's,
I mean,
I really appreciate boxing.
I love it as a sport.
I love it as a,
as a,
just as a martial art.
I appreciate the elite of the elite,
but it's,
it's not as wild the UFC because there's takedowns and kicks and strangle holds
and armbars it's just way more wild.
Yeah.
It's way,
it's way more exciting.
A street fight.
It's like a super technical street fight between trained killers.
That's what it's like.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
Well listen,
I want to thank you.
I want to thank,
you know,
I made it.
I want to thank you.
I mean,
listen,
when me,
when I was coming in with like a boxing show,
we just did cares.
They say you don't have it,
Mohammed.
We can do whatever we want,
man.
This is the beautiful thing about podcasts.
You do whatever the fuck you want,
but you were a big inspiration of mine,
you and,
and,
uh,
all those legends of Boston comedy.
And to this day,
I think I saw some of the best comedy of my life ever.
Um,
when I was a young man coming up and when I was just starting out and you know,
opening for guys like you and you know,
you know,
you know what made it special is nobody was doing it as a job.
We were all just doing it because they said I want to do this.
Yeah.
You know,
and there was no forethought or afterthought.
It was just,
I mean that's what I still love about
performing,
you know,
acting or stand up.
It's,
you're in the moment,
right?
Right.
You're in the moment.
But Fitzsimmons is a good buddy of mine and uh,
Greg Fitzsimmons and we started out together.
We talk about it to this day that back then we didn't think of having a career.
Like what are you talking about?
A career though.
The best thing that we could ever envision was one day would be able to pay our
bills.
Doing stand up comedy.
That's right.
That's all we would hope for because I would look at guys like you or all the,
the,
the Boston guys that were getting,
you know,
they were making a living.
I was like,
these guys know.
I'm like,
Geez,
I watched this,
those guys,
myself and I was in awe guys like Kenny Rogers Center thing.
Sure.
What a mind Stephen.
Right?
I mean,
they do things I can't do,
you know,
and they,
the way they can create jokes.
Oh,
I did a movie with Rodney back to school and I'd just watch him,
you know,
create these jokes.
You know,
like the one line,
like a Haiku poem.
I go to the dentist the other day for yellow teeth.
He says,
we're a brown tie.
You know,
your mind's going in one direction.
Yeah.
I'll tell you another guy who was a fantastic joke writer.
Uh,
he could,
he,
the jokes he did,
he couldn't,
you couldn't do now is Martin Mall Martin Mall from Martin Martin.
That television show was at would tonight.
He was on the tonight show and uh,
Johnny said,
how you doing?
And he said,
Johnny,
I'm as busy as jumper cables that are Puerto Rican wedding.
You couldn't do that joke today.
So already say,
he said,
uh,
I was watching roots with 20 minutes.
No one scored a basket.
I turned it off.
By the way,
that's Martin Mall.
It's not made
and it's not.
Joe,
did you like,
um,
the,
the documentary when standups stood out?
I did not participate in that.
How come?
Because,
uh,
I didn't want my family to go through watching that.
How so?
What do you mean?
Oh,
it was about the decadence of it all and drugs and all that.
I like to think,
you know,
the important thing is the work.
Yeah.
You know,
well,
it was a little bit about the decadence,
but it was also about,
I was paranoid about Cremins and those guys.
Yeah.
I'm very,
very,
it was very sad,
but I was very happy to,
to know him and to,
I used to say to Barry,
I'd be on a Gig with Barry
and I'd say,
Barry,
you're making these people are here to drink.
You're making references to the third under secretary of State's policy and
fricking Uganda.
They are not going to get it.
Yeah.
So you can't get mad at them for not getting it.
But he was,
you know,
I didn't agree with his politics at all,
but he really meant it.
Yes.
So I respected that.
Well,
he's a very smart guy and he also had extremely powerful ethics.
Like he was one of the reasons why no one respected any hacks in Boston.
Now,
many thieves were punished as it was a,
it was because of Barry.
Like you had to have original material.
Absolutely.
And everybody policed it.
It was a very unique environment because Rodney Dangerfield said that,
he said,
when somebody steal the joke from me,
it's like,
like the hidden Mana.
My kids
feel that personal,
you know?
Well,
you know how it is when you're working on a bid and it doesn't work well in the
beginning,
and then,
you know,
it takes months to figure out how to twist it and perfect it,
and then someone comes along and takes the finished product.
It's,
it's a horrific thing.
Yeah.
You know,
but Barry made sure that that environment of Boston was not,
it was,
it wasn't just that it was,
there was no,
there was no thieves.
There was also no hacks.
Like if you were doing like cop donut jokes or Sheila,
he would just fucking spit in your face.
He didn't want none of,
you know,
Barry was a,
and he was a scary guy,
man.
I remember when I was a,
an open Mike,
I was so intimidated by him and when he started being nice to me,
I was like,
Whoa,
Woo.
I made it through.
I was so worried that he was going to hate me.
I was so worried he was going to hate me.
Well,
I was worried that all those guys are going to hate me.
And you guys were all doing yes.
Well,
you're terrible.
You're terrible when you're first starting out and you see guys like you and
Calvin.
And I was always,
you know,
I was felt like I was never going to be inside.
I was never gonna make it,
you know,
it's just,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I was,
I just felt like it was unattainable and you guys were the cane
and now like I said,
you opened for me,
you're going to going to hit the big time.
That's what the movie's about.
And by the way is Boston comedy.
Yeah,
we shoot it at the cow alone.
We shoot it downtown and we shoot all over the city.
It's about Boston.
It's about comedy and a,
I hope people come out and see it tonight.
Thursday.
It's at the Lameer musical here in Beverly Hills.
Oh is it really this Thursday?
Shit.
Do you want to go?
Yeah,
I would love to go.
What time is it?
Seven 30 I have a show at eight.
I'm at the Improv boy.
Shit.
Well either.
Even if I can't make it on Thursday.
Um,
I will definitely.
Yeah,
I'm at the Improv at eight o'clock unfortunately.
But I spent a lot of nights at the Improv Improv on Hollywood,
on Melrose and Hollywood.
It's a great spot.
But was there,
it was great.
Those audiences were fantastic.
They still are to this day.
I've been doing a lot of shit.
I'm there tomorrow night.
I'm there Thursday night as well.
I'm there.
I'm trying to do more shows there.
Could,
I'll mix it up cause I mostly just do the comedy store when I'm in town and the
Ice House in Pasadena.
Did you ever do that place?
I think so.
How long are you in town for?
Friday morning and flying out,
but yeah.
What are you doing tomorrow night?
You want to do a set at the Improv?
Sure.
Why not?
Why Not Sweetie?
Tuesday.
Tomorrow night's Tuesday.
Why not come on baby.
All right.
That'd be fun.
You get to be on w yeah,
you're,
you're going to be on for sure.
Yeah.
It'll be hot then people will know you from the shell.
All right.
Yeah.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
Um,
so when you did decided to do this,
this,
this movie about Boston comedy and you didn't want to do that,
uh,
that went standup stood out documentary.
That was many years ago.
What is,
so you,
you knew it was just going to be about the deck and it's up,
but there's also documenting what standup was like and I didn't know what it
would be.
So you just decided,
yeah.
You know,
it was one of those decisions,
you know,
it's like,
um,
sometimes you make decisions that are really fucked up.
Like,
do you remember Ed Mcmahon had a show?
What was it?
Star?
What?
Star search?
No,
it was something Ed Mcmahon had this,
wasn't he star search.
Yeah.
We'll start with that.
What it was Kevin James One.
So,
so I'm auditioning for this show and I'm saying here I am auditioning for a show
I don't want to do and I've been turned down,
you know,
so I said,
wow,
this is,
this is awful.
I did a lot of that sitcoms that I really didn't want and then,
or a movies rather than,
I really didn't want to like the Adam anyway.
No,
no.
I retired.
I'm retired 100% from acting.
Wow.
Yeah.
Last movie I did was a Kevin James Movie,
but it's Kevin's a buddy of mine and I would,
I would do something with him just for,
for a goof.
But I don't enjoy acting.
I don't enjoy sitcoms.
I don't enjoy actors.
I like comics too much.
I liked hanging around with comedians so much.
The one I'm hanging around with actors,
I'm like,
God,
I wish you guys were comics
comics or they don't have any filter.
They're loose.
You know where you stand with,
you know,
where you stand with them.
If they like you,
they really like it and they're accepting of weird shit and flaws like,
hey,
it's fucking crazy.
What are you going to do?
It's funny though,
you know they're little people say shit like that.
Like,
you know what they used to say to me,
say or all these comedians on drugs and I'd say no,
only the good ones I can.
George Carlin and Richard Pryor.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well they're the,
the wild,
impulsive people.
But a lot of them,
you know,
like Bill Hicks got off the drugs and was probably even better when he was off
the drugs,
but it had a lot of great drug stories.
Oh yeah,
it did.
You look back and there are great stories as long as you can look back and as
long as they're just stories.
Yeah.
As long as you're not in jail and as long as you get through.
And they're funny when you look back.
But then not so funny when you're in the middle of it.
Well,
the Ding Ho,
when you guys were starting out,
that was,
that was the legendary place.
That was what we'd all,
I'd come a little bit too late.
I think the dino and closed,
it was a bartender there named Henry
and I'd always ask this crazy question.
I think,
is he an asshole or is he Chinese though?
It's like,
you know,
mutually exclusive,
Chinese,
you know,
they don't know if they're pissed off.
It's like,
oh,
well you go,
do you want Sweeney and Sweeney not here.
Swinging out again.
You know,
I'm,
I'm on the phone.
Yeah,
I'm swinging.
He,
yeah.
Sweden and not tell.
We don't know where Sweeney or,
you know,
I'm Sweeney,
I'm trying to get in there,
you know.
Um,
yeah,
the thing,
Whoa,
that was,
that was wild.
The guy lost the place in a dominoes game.
No,
his name was Sean Lee and he compulsive gambler.
And so it was a Chinese restaurant with a theater,
like the w or a restaurant,
that thing.
Whole restaurant.
But there was a stage,
there was a stage,
but the,
you know,
one time it came in,
the doors were locked.
He lost it and what you guys would think of as a card game.
But apparently it played dominoes gambling.
And how did it get started?
How the Ding Ho gets Cremins Crimmons started,
you know,
Cremins what was going on before then?
There was no comedy club,
no comedy.
And what year was this?
Well,
I don't know.
I don't remember anything like that to seven eight.
It May.
If it was the nineties I don't remember what day of it,
but it closed in [inaudible] 84 right.
I don't remember what it was.
I think he calls an 84 because it was gone.
Like it was a legend when I came around.
I came around in 88 and people are like,
Oh,
you missed the Dang,
whoa.
We all had our own shows there.
I was Sunday nights and I do all these crazy characters.
I was just trying to,
you know,
find out what I want to do,
you know?
So I was doing like characters,
but one week that's when the magic happened is Peter was solid from the tonight
show came in and at the time the tonight show was the tonight show.
He saw Stephen,
right.
And the next week Steven Wright was on the tonight show.
It was amazing,
you know,
because we're there already what we were catapulted from Inman square fricking
Chinese restaurants who Johnny Carson,
who was amazing.
It was wonderful.
When did the other clubs started opening up?
It was after that when they,
when people found out there was some money in it,
but then it was in the suburbs and it was all over the place.
Do you remember that?
There was one time where there was duck soup across from so soup was Nick's
comedy stop down the street from Nick's comedy stop was the comedy channel and
above it was common at the Charles Playoffs member.
Mike Clark was booking common at the Charles playhouse for awhile.
So there was four clubs on the same block that's right in Boston.
And you know what?
They were all filled,
the same guys were working in all of them.
And everybody was shuffling around,
but the shows were filled.
They couldn't,
was great.
Going next was doing three shows in three different rooms.
Yeah.
They were doing the disco downstairs.
They had the smaller middle room and then they had the upper and one Saturday
night I did stitches,
which was uncommon map.
I did three shows there.
I did four,
I did about nine shows in one night.
And at the end of the night I was just,
I was saying that the audience did I already do that.
Joe
and I was so tired was like,
I'd be like setting it up and then what's the fucking punchline of this shit?
Yeah.
You know,
in some point of diminishing returns,
sometimes you're not even thinking about what you're doing right.
And,
um,
they're not laughing.
And I say,
then you say,
well,
you realize you're not saying it right.
You're not delivering it.
And you know,
then you deliver it and they laugh.
And then there's this other voice in your mind saying,
wow,
that's interesting.
If I change my voice,
they'll laugh.
And it's like me watching me do this.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
I can remember if you want to hear a horrible coke story,
I was down in New York,
I was up for a show called,
not necessarily the news,
I remember that.
So we backstage at catch a rising star and that plays,
you know,
when somebody comes out to see on these shows,
they're always late.
So I'm downstairs and the guy says they're not here yet and this,
all right,
so do you want to do a line?
I said,
all right,
I'm fucking,
you know,
so I did it and not send out.
Now time is going faster because you fucked up.
And I said the here yet.
And I said,
well,
you just asked five minutes ago,
no,
they're not here.
Do you want to do another line?
I said,
yeah,
okay,
I'll do.
So I got,
by the time I'm on stage,
it's like,
oh,
I'm fucking,
you know,
there's no comedy.
You know when your jam him,
it's like at the intensity is fucking unbelievable.
You're on stage like this.
So they were there to see me and I go out and I did this and I was like setting
up a joke and not doing the punchline and start and shit and ideas.
And it was fucked up.
It was like Charlie Sheen,
you know what I mean?
There's no dots to put together.
It's not supposed to make any sense.
I go off and I said to the kid,
how was it?
He said,
He was supposed to do 25 minutes.
He did four minutes.
I thought it was out there for like an hour.
It's fucking off is when I think of those days.
When did you quit?
26 years.
What was the reason?
You know,
when I talk to kids,
they,
they say that sometimes what?
And the closest thing I can say is something we'd say the program,
I was sick and tired of being sick and tired.
I was always exhausted.
Yeah.
Always tired.
So then I came back to life,
you know,
and now I enjoy every day.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
And I enjoyed being on the show and join having,
yeah.
Thanks buddy.
Thanks man.
I appreciate you for it.
All right.
Thanks,
sir.
We can do it again.
We will.
And you,
you're going to be at the Improv tomorrow night.
8:00 PM show.
Right?
You know what?
I'll come and watch you come on mother fucking [inaudible].
Yes.
Well,
I'm on,
I close.
I'm on last,
so I'll go on at like nine,
something like that.
Yeah,
I'll do five minutes.
Alright,
beautiful.
Alright.
Sweeney ladies and gentlemen and a Sweeney killing Sweeney.
Uh,
you can get it on iTunes and a couple of days.
Preordered thanks sir.
All right,
thanks.